what people don't realize about Keith
Richards is in the early days you were a
guy very happy you and Mick were very
happy sort of being these two guys who
interpreted blues music from America but
then you guys start writing music and
this blows my mind you don't write it
for the stones you write it for other
people you guys become songwriters the
first song as tears go by even really
you wrote that for Mary and faithful
right yeah I mean not for the stones
when we wrote this uh it was our first
song that Mick and I had written and
Andrew oldum bless his heart uh a genius
uh producer and mentor of the day I said
listen guys we can't do covers forever
you know and he locked he locked Mick
and Me in the kitchen and said see come
out with a song but here's what people
don't know this these are songs you
wrote for other people not for the
stones this is a song called that girl
belongs to by Jean Pitney you guys wrote
This what I don't understand that phase
of your life you go off you write a song
you think it's great and you hand it to
Jean
Pitney I'd give it to anybody man who
gave it to Jean Pitney Andrew oldum well
here's some songs you you wrote this is
Bobby Jameson all I want is my baby I
can't remember this one you don't
remember it you wrote it
listen
[Music]
do you remember surprise surprise by
Lulu you surpris
me you wrote this I know that but now
what do you feel listening to
this I'm amazed she took it out but
there was some this was our learning
process Mick and Me trying we come out
with the weirdest songs and and
Let it Fly you know and so you let it
fly and then what would happen like
months later you'd hear someone
performing it or on the yeah Andrew was
good at you know placing these things
and uh I mean we didn't think they were
any good at all you know wow but uh at
the same time I think Andrew Alm was
giving us leeway to sort of figure out
oh youan writing songs is is is is not
something that happens overnight you
know you have to learn and stuff and we
were like making the writing the sort of
Pop crap yeah but when you writing it
when you're writing it you're making
some money right I mean these you paid
yeah it's starting to and do you
remember wait do you remember this one
hold on listen to this Cliff Richard
this is your
song Blue turns to gray
well he
did you're Keith Richard you have to
know you wrote this yeah I remember the
[Music]
title this is this is amazing to me that
you like if I wrote any song that
anybody recorded it would but I guess
you've written so many songs you you
forget yeah to us this was all practice
you know to us the important thing was
like finally to get to write a song for
The Rolling Stones you know that we
could put in front of the guys that I
could put in front of Charlie Watts and
Brian Jones and
say how do you feel about this and
they'd go yeah that really first song
that went big in England is the last
time the last time that was the one I
was thinking of yeah yeah this is the
one see then we fin it we got to write
for the stones you know this is a stone
song in other words you can't give this
the Lulu and basically a lot of it
borrowed from The Staple
Singers when you guys wrote this and it
became a hit in England you must have
been beside yourself I mean that's the
moment you know both sides
myself but do you do you do you and Mick
just go oh my God I love you yeah
because we can do it man we can now
write songs for the band you know
because before that as you just played
you know there's other songs these are
all like experiments of like just how to
write a song and put it together and
um the last time was the thing that b
now okay now we got it now all we got to
do now is like get better at
it